just wrapped up the end of day six today
was the table read where everyone
showcased their scripts for the first
time table reads are always so much more
awkward than I would anticipate it's
just a lot of dead space and silence I
am really feeling the time crunch with
this class now the panic seems to sort
of be setting into the students one at
the end of class they would like our
stuff is due next thursday basically i
do think that their scripts are in much
much better form than they were last
week i guess i wonder if it's more
valuable for them for me to just give
them the feedback online which is what i
did for half of them versus talk during
these group table reads but i also think
it's really important for them to be
able to read the scripts allowed in
front of the class and to get some of
the input from their classmates of an
Andhra brought up really good points to
PJ or Paul at the end and that would
have happened if I I thought that didn't
happen when I was just sending him
comments through google docs there's a
fine line between sort of constructive
criticism and just doing the work for
them I super tempted over the weekend to
just say like change this word to this
it sort of be there editor and I did
like that because I think it's more
valuable for them to sort of discover
that on their own but the problems that
take so much time and it's time that we
don't have it's been a challenge to
balance that so far I think it will
continue to be a challenge adjusting
assignments on the fly and adjusting
lecture materials on the fly and taking
stuff out a lot of stuff that actually
has been not the easiest thing to do I
had a very interesting discussion with
sary after class about if this class
could really be feasible in a semester
in the style of the semester you can't
really break up a shirt into 45 minute
chunks like Josh's storyboarding lecture
wouldn't have it made any sense in only
45 minutes maybe eight cut out but it
wouldn't have been is it would have been
so different and its really inefficient
to just shoot for 45
when it's at a time well all I feel
antsy I feel very antsy I feel antsy for
the students it's going to be a sprint
to the end